[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en esta
oportunidad conversaremos con el señor
armando bojórquez él es presidente de la
asociación para la cultura y el turismo
en américa latina' señor bojórquez
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y comienzo por preguntarle cuál es el
balance que usted hace del año 2020 para
la industria del turismo en medio del
marco de esta pandemia hablo en términos
de puestos de trabajos perdidos y cómo
se afectó a la industria turística
bueno muchas gracias por esta
oportunidad la verdad es que en el caso
por ejemplo de algunos países de américa
latina se han perdido millones de
trabajos
en el caso por ejemplo de méxico o hemos
tenido más de un millón de empleos
perdidos por ejemplo cuatro y medio
millones de empleos directos se utilizan
aquí en méxico para
de ti turismo y más los indirectos que
vienen siendo mucho más sin embargo de
empleos directos se han perdido más de
un millón de empleos durante 2020 y se
espera que 2021 pueda ser similar o peor
dada las circunstancias que se presenta
actualmente en el mundo del turismo
señor por qué es
la pandemia tomó por sorpresa al mundo
entero pero qué tan preparada o qué tan
fortalecida estaba la industria
turística latinoamericana para hacer
frente a esta crisis como lo ha hecho
hasta ahora
bueno realmente la gente no estaba
preparada adecuadamente para recibir la
crisis ha sido una crisis que han
golpeado fuertemente al sector turístico
a nivel mundial ha sido peor muchos
dicen que la segunda guerra mundial y es
cierto porque se ha prolongado ya un año
prácticamente estamos cumpliendo de esta
pandemia el sector hotelero por ejemplo
ha pasado por una crisis grave porque
sus ocupaciones son muy bajas o mínimas
hay muchos hoteles cerrados
tenemos también tiempo la hotelería
formal recibió un duro golpe al
principio con la serbia y después vino
el problema de la pandemia y ahora
vendrá otro problema también para la
hotelería formal que será la tecnología
porque habrá un gran descenso en el
turismo de negocios y el turismo maíz
sobre todo el turismo de meetings
incentives congress a nivel social del
ser el turismo de eventos y convenciones
que también se verá seriamente afectado
y que creemos nosotros también que
largará mucho en su recuperación sí así
que esto va para largo será de acuerdo a
su perspectiva al 2021 no va a ser un
año muy positivo de acuerdo a lo que
usted está diciendo
pese a las aperturas de los países en
los procesos de vacunación en el turismo
no comenzará a dar una marcha hacia una
actividad positiva
noten definitivamente esto va a andar
desde lo mínimo dos años o tres o cuatro
años desgraciadamente y vemos que la
situación no será fácil también habrá
una gran competencia entre los países
por captar este tipo de turismo
la competencia será
a bajo bajo precio desgraciadamente eso
se ocasionará un decremento en los
ingresos de los prestadores de servicios
turísticos y habrá una competencia entre
países para captar el mayor número de
turistas esto definitivamente nos va a
llevar a una situación que va a tardar
de 3 a 4 años en recuperarse y
turísticas puede pedir apoyos
gubernamentales apoyos a los bancos para
poder salir adelante pero también la
cadena de valor del turismo es muy
grande todos los prestadores que están
alrededor se importante es ese punto que
usted destaca señor bojórquez que tanto
compromiso y que tanto engranaje ha
habido por parte de los gobiernos para
ayudar a reactivar la industria
turística o incentivos
muy bajos los incentivos que ha habido
desgraciadamente una de las cosas que
estamos pidiendo a nivel américa latina'
escritor y no sea de verdad considerado
prioridad mundial y prioridad nacional
en cada uno de los países prioridad que
realmente existan apoyos claros y
diversos porque si no la cadena de valor
se va a ver seriamente afectado porque
no solamente son los hoteleros son las
agencias de viajes los transportistas
los guías de turistas las tiendas de
artesanía todos estos que tienen que ver
con esta cadena de valor tan importante
en el sector turístico es urgente tomar
medidas y crear valor agregado sí señor
armando bojórquez gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en cinco minutos con
alquien france24 ustedes pueden seguir
con nuestra programación
[Música]